yeah welcome to a new video playing
against GM here from this is Bosnia I am
yeah Bosnia let's check the name um II
bros are rich Zollitsch okay so um what
do we have modern depends on yeah our
Kings Indian now let's go to the Kings
Indian always entertaining to play no
well not always but most of the time
classical Kings Indian with before i
play my old special line with King h8 to
test some points it's not a great line I
cannot fully recommend it but then it's
not so bad okay so let's see them how
does unfolding here let's go here I want
to stop there a 5 p-6 thing with playing
b6 matter of course it's the usual
picture I'm already busted on the
queenside but of course you're you have
your hopes to to deliver mate on the
other side
yeah this King h8 moonfire looked at
years ago when I was playing the Kings
Indian on a regular basis f3 okay is it
an idea come on let's let's try this get
the night to get the Knight to f4 aha 25
isn't this dangerous it looks dangerous
wow he's very relaxed about all this
okay come on check this is the Kings
Indian we used to play anything anything
too sophisticated let's get at the King
here I just need Bishop age 62 III or
something and it's over you can go
Queenie one but I then I can simply
check and play Bishop age 6 and this is
dangerous it really is oh I can can play
the check okay this i need to do anyway
so let's get on with this and I could
also consider to take only form so that
i can use the rook hmm I don't know but
Bishop h6 looks like the normal move it
cannot play a form come on he cannot
play F for c3 is just saying okay this
callousness and i have i have Bishop to
f4 at least i could again consider
taking here this night this night if i
would get rid of the night
mm yeah this is the kind of position
where you feel that it's probably not
really working for black but it's really
dangerous in a practical game take and
Bishop f5
yeah I need to open up open up lines
here so now you should f5
are very crude moves like regular crook
to f4 look at formal to see replying on
that look at for Queen f2 maybe
this should inform
ah
I try this this MOOC age five it's super
difficult I mean probably it is not
really working for black so at least my
wife my feeling and it's a it's it is
dangerous
no Bishop h3 is the idea coming with the
temple on the Queen
yeah d 6 is also hanging maybe he can
simply take it maybe they're always some
some ideas so hmm
I want to pawn on their form this would
really help my cause so that I control
g3 and Bishop e3 is even more powerful
now Bishop e3 sm the idea now
yeah very tense
so that's another way to go it's
threatening tween edge I probably need
to do that not much else
and we can maybe play Bishop f1 simply
okay this is a pin kind of a self pin
I know yeah now he's get rid of the pin
I thought I could do something with with
the pin but I obviously there was
nothing okay and I also very much down
on the clock I can resign that it wasn't
resign I'm a natural optimist in chess
but I really thought that this should
should be something yeah computer does
things I why this winning yeah I
suspected this but it looks so earth so
tricky I took and when this is evil the
computer line even this I hit all the
computer moves until now and it says
about equal you should see one also the
best one and this it says it's a mistake
okay so what am I supposed to do yeah I
like this Bishop our formulas I thought
it was good
Bishop age three now can I mean I get
the exchange so that it is from material
point of view I'm a playable position
between here
and the computer says this is around
equal hmm well six yeah I think white is
better here the two nights are very very
strong I'm always in big danger of
losing d6 probably I will lose it at
some point and then the deep ball is
very strong yeah this is not equal yeah
well okay this this is the sacrificer
was a was choked a bit bit dicey yep but
it is interested in you need to try to
to do those things once in a while what
I was wondering um before let's just
just briefly okay it went the check just
this this just briefly it looks at your
sneakiness but sometimes those slower
texts are not so not so terrible now I
guess he gets to h2 immediately if you
have a bit of time like something like
this this is sometimes possible but I'm
simply I don't have any pieces yeah it's
it's it's ridiculous so maybe this this
wasn't so great yes my it was
interesting hope you enjoyed it thanks